the waning power of a buck
means we'll need to carry money around
in a truck
have you noticed less product in the
container than the media thinks you're
just a complainer so like jumping into a
cold pool in the summer inflation makes
something smaller
at 7.9 percent companies are downsizing
products using the same packaging but
keeping the price the same it's known
online as shrink flation and consumers
are taking notice apparently bounty
crest doritos and even wheat thins are
just some of the products that downsized
in 2021
their business model is tricking people
like when my drug dealer adds baby
laxative
but they've already caught they're
already called wheat thins
if they get any thinner we'll have to
call them wheat models
would say thank you for sexist i need
this job yes meanwhile the media still
toes the line that biden has nothing to
do with inflation
can we have an honest conversation about
gas prices because too much of the u.s
media chatter is distorted to the point
of being dishonest higher gas prices is
a small sacrifice to make many
politicians act as though
it's president biden who caused
inflation and that he can fix this no i
mean you know he did not cause the war
which caused prices to surge and you
heard the president united states say
putin's price hike putin's price hike a
putin price hike putin's price hike
and putin's price hike is a great way to
message it
oh boy and they are on message they
carry more of biden's water than his
pants
so what caused that inflation we knew
coveted relief money didn't help but at
least it went to good use am i right huh
not really just 23 of the 800 billion
given out by the paycheck protection
program actually went to workers more
than 87 billion in unemployment benefits
were improperly paid and the irs gave
3.5 billion to dead people probably to
aid democrat voters r.i.p
and as for inflation no industry is safe
no grandma i never spend my money on
stupid stuff all right not in this
economy
oh i gotta go my male escort is here all
right i ordered a big one this time
are you brittany wow yeah sign here
please
enjoy
wait you are from humungoushunks.com
yeah well i mean there's inflation but
it's the same price it's just a subtle
difference in the packaging
[Music]
i don't think anybody in fox is tackling
inflation the way we do charles i
haven't seen
you how inflation affects the male
escort business quite
such a
such
anyway
okay
they're all denying it's it's brian's
fault but
how can you the effects are a direct
cause i brought a prop unfortunately i
should have given it to you
this is the cpi chart right okay and
this arrow is when president graphics on
television right there okay yeah
from that arrow it went straight up
that's called parabolic that's like you
know when you shoot a rocket into space
so arrow biden inflation that way uh
there's your your there's your evidence
that yeah it was not a problem cpi 1.4
january 2021 almost 8 today probably 10
next month listen that last tranche of
cash you gave out i know i know the
political calculus you paid for votes i
mean it's pretty simple right it's dirty
politics 101 or maybe politics 101 you
buy votes so how about a quick 1.9
trillion in the kitty yeah you know what
i knew it was a problem about a few
months after that when they were talking
about buildback better they took these
polls
and i'm talking polls from cnn yeah nbc
people are saying no more no moss i'm
afraid more free money will harm my
family that's when you knew it was back
firing yeah cat excellent acting uh and
i i i i almost felt like i was there
i almost did too you've been writing a
blog on inflation for years
so what's your expert opinion on this
are you upset by the shrink-flation
i don't know if i care i mean i should
care but i you know when you don't care
yeah i don't care for a family you've
got a family no fewer sheets of toilet
paper yes yeah yeah yeah i don't care i
provided you actually used toilet paper
yeah when i buy snacks when i buy snacks
i like i'm always eating them late at
night too much then i just throw them
all in the trash because i'm gonna eat
it all and
so um for normal people though it
probably matters yeah and if you have
kids and if you have kids also don't
have that yeah uh but again
that i know of again
this is why
this is why
whenever you know we say when they're
pumping money in the economy hey you
know this is going to happen and then it
happens but the people on the left say
you know you're just horrible people you
want people to starve and be poor and
all that's true for some people like you
you don't care if people started i died
yes uh it's not really the case with all
of us we knew this was not hard to
predict everybody predicted this yes
tyrus you must be well everything is
tiny compared to you i don't think any
man's ever comfortable with shrinkage
i think across the board i think we all
agree with that yes um just one more
thing that was your grandmother you're
on the phone with correct
don't let that slide by that was genius
she's used to it hey
she's such a sweetheart
don't work blue
when you
we're forgetting about this
population of people they they talk
about oh misappropriations of funds
there was a lot of mom and pops and a
lot of minorities and women in
particular that were destroyed because
they were approved for this help money
and it never came right and they made
investments they took out loans when
they were waiting for the the money to
come in for the restaurant repro uh what
was it i figured it's called with our
payroll protection that payroll
protection all that stuff they made
loans to cover their losses while they
were waiting for this while they got a
letter from the government saying you
were approved for this amount of money
and it never came
and now they're looking they're bit
we're seeing businesses go up go up go
up
out of business because they are
in the red when they were already in the
red and the government never came
through yeah and they're just so lacks
the days ago well this is a thing that
happens and
it's not a thing that happens and
there's no there's no rope for them
and then you look at the whole thing
with the the gas thing i forgot i took a
picture i think it was in january and i
was like thanks a lot because i'm
obsessed with gas prices because our
previous administration he made such a
big deal out of it yeah i took a picture
and posted it it was 405
in mandeville louisiana before it was
like 2 25 and that was back in january
and i i don't think putin was doing
what's causing our inflation and our
prices to go up then guy at the library
has might has the inflation shrinkage
affected the fining the fines no people
are coming in all the time because they
don't want to pay for books right right
so it's actually great for us right
you're seeing a resurgence not just
among chronic homeless [ __ ] but
among uh among actual readers really
getting passionate about the dewey
decimal system again we'd love to see it
i want to thank you greg for not
directing a question about male escorts
to me for once
thank you um here's what bothers me
about this story and the blame game is
it true that what's happening in ukraine
what putin is doing is contributing to
this yes are there things out of biden's
control that are also fueling this
absolutely are there policy things that
the white house has done and the
democrats have done in their unified
government that are also contributing
obviously we'd be morons not to believe
that it's nuanced there's a combination
of factors
all of these media news people
talking about oh it's just so unfair to
pin this all on biden it just happened
to start going up precipitously as soon
as he takes office it's not fair let's
fact check this to death
fine i mean some of that is is fine to
point that out
you know
that if this exact phenomenon and
combination of factors were happening
under the previous president there would
be no nuance this would be all on trump
everything else all the excuses any
sought any seeking out of nuance would
be completely attacked and dismissed and
it doesn't bother me that much at the
end of the day because i don't think
it's really fooling anyone i don't think
it's really working yeah like like biden
wanted this job he got it he owns this
and if it's not 100 his fault fine but
it is increasingly close to 100 his
problem there you go all right we gotta
move on
up next citizens arm themselves with
pepper spray to keep gun-toting thugs at
bay